[Música]
y volvemos con más noticias económicas
de la mano de nuestra periodista daniela
blandón daniela bienvenida de nuevo un
placer tenerla otra vez aquí gracias
mañana empezamos por el salvador y
quiero que nos explique todo esto del
bitcoin porque el país cumple un año con
la cripta moneda como su moneda de curso
legal claro que sí pues su moneda de
curso lugar la junto con el dólar este
aniversario llega en medio de críticas
por el leve impacto que ha tenido para
la economía de ese país que sigue
todavía muy polarizada y también la poca
información pública de la estrategia
económica del presidente nayib ukelele
quien sigue gozando de alta popularidad
y es que el mandatario salvadoreño quien
era muy activo en redes promocionando el
bitcoin lleva dos meses sin mencionarlo
el bureau of economic research reveló en
julio que sólo el 20 por ciento de la
población usa la billetera gubernamental
creada para usar los bitcoins de hecho
el 80 por ciento de las personas que
descargaron la aplicación no la volvió
ni siquiera a tocar pues muchos lo
hicieron para cobrar ese bono de 30
dólares que regalaba en ese momento el
gobierno
bueno y si la mayoría lo hizo por este
bono o no la mayoría sino muchos que ha
pasado un año después bueno le invito a
que saque papel y lápiz calculadora
porque mire hoy un bitcoin cuesta poco
más de 18 mil dólares hace un año valía
43 mil 50 dólares es decir ha perdido
más del 56 por ciento de su valor en un
año el gobierno del salvador dice haber
acumulado dos mil 381 en el último año
eso quiere decir que lo que hace un año
habría costado 102 millones de dólares
hoy costaría apenas 44 7 millones de
dólares bueno y cambiamos totalmente de
tema porque rusia amenaza de nuevo
occidente con los hidrocarburos hubo
cruce de declaraciones úrsula von der
leyen la presidenta de la comisión
europea propuso imponerles un tope a los
precios del gas ruso y el presidente
ruso vladimir putin amenazó con dejar de
exportar los escuchemos estas
declaraciones
nuestro objetivo es reducir los costos
del gas y por lo tanto propondremos un
precio tope para el gas ruso con racing
gas
así que aquí el objetivo es que debemos
recortar los ingresos de rusia que putin
utiliza para financiar su atroz guerra
en ucrania simplemente no cumpliremos
con los contratos no suministraremos más
y va en contra de nuestros intereses
económicos en este caso no
suministraremos gas petróleo carbón o
combustible para calefacción nada
cumpliremos nuestras obligaciones
contractuales en su totalidad pero si
alguien trata de imponernos algo
entonces quiero enfatizar esto aquellos
que nos impongan algo no están en una
posición hoy para dictar no su voluntad
necesitan pensar mejor al respecto
lección y muy bien que que esto daniela
y ya comienzan a conocerse los planes
económicos de reino unido con eso bueno
pues el nuevo ministro de finanzas de
gran bretaña al squash y quart n se
reunió hoy mismo con los banqueros e
inversionistas dijo que es un nuevo
enfoque económico incluye apoyo
inmediato para las familias y empresas
para abordar el costo de vida y también
un compromiso con la sostenibilidad
fiscal pero sí reconoció que el gobierno
necesitará pedir prestado más de lo
planeado para cumplirlo mientras tanto
el instructor compareció ante el
parlamento primera vez como primera
ministra gonzález estoy contestando
quiero que sigamos haciendo frente a esa
atroz agresión rusa que ha llevado a la
crisis energética que enfrentamos ahora
estoy en contra de un impuesto sobre las
ganancias inesperadas
creo que es incorrecto desanimar a las
empresas de invertir en el reino unido
justo cuando necesitamos hacer crecer la
economía
y en más noticias económicas a nivel a
una empresa de bateo de eeuu acordó
pagar una millonaria suma cuando bueno
yo le tengo un acuerdo como no tengo
cifra del día entonces vamos de una vez
con este tema 440 millones de dólares
fue lo que acordó pagar el fabricante de
cigarrillos electrónicos llull el lapso
para resolver una investigación de dos
años sobre sus productos en 33 estados
más puerto rico durante años se ha
culpado a sus productos de mapeo con
alto contenido de nicotina de provocar
un aumento nacional en su uso por parte
de adolescentes ahora veamos el valor de
este acuerdo equivale a una cuarta parte
de los ingresos de la compañía en 2021
por unos mil 900 millones de dólar esto
la convierte en una empresa bastante
importante porque tiene una tercera
parte del mercado de eeuu aunque lejos
de ese 75% que llegó a representar hace
algunos años uno de los fiscales
garantes del acuerdo se refirió el tema
él se refirió al tema y dijo que no van
a volver a hacer lo que estaban haciendo
con los estadounidenses sobre todo con
los jóvenes de llevarlos a este vicio
del papel y no teníamos cifra pero sí
tenemos indicadores y señora wall street
abrió mixto hacia cerró con pérdidas
influenciadas por las acciones de eeuu
que valga la pena mencionar acumula en
su cuarta semana consecutiva de pérdidas
prevalece por supuesto el pesimismo
sobre las tasas de interés unos precios
al consumidor que no se den pese al
endurecimiento de esta política
monetaria en europa los ojos del mercado
desde luego están puestos sobre la
reunión del banco central europeo de
este jueves en la que ya hacen sus
apuestas sobre subidas agresivas en las
tasas de interés tal y como les haciendo
la reserva federal y también muy
influenciadas también por toda esta
crisis energética bueno daniela gracias
y nos vemos mañana con más información
así es y yo la invito